we wanted to start the show on the right
note so we got Henry Winkler in here
Henry oh yeah look at all that purple
purple sweater purple jacket Wow
you are looking bright purple you do I
do you do why did you do you believe in
like the the Fung Shui of colors like do
you want to know what I don't know but
it when I put the color on it changes
the way I feel it does yesterday I was
wearing a brown shirt and I changed it
to a red shirt uh-huh and I just perked
right up is that right yeah Wow
so all that time is the funds you must
have been like I got to change the color
of this jacket but you know what I just
ended that it was red I see I am and you
know the black leather jacket which
actually was brown it just photographed
black I see yeah I see so are you
visualization I'm good man I'm very very
good how are you how unbelievable yeah
yeah yeah it seems like things are good
is this uh well last night we premiered
better late than never right the new
show right and the tweets that I got
like oh my gosh well who would have
thought I think it's so funny cuz better
late than never
is is it's like it's a I wants a reality
show it's an underrated show it is it's
an unscripted show but reality show it
sounds like it's fake right like reality
show this is by the seat of our pants
right we're in six countries we're in
you know we have five cameras no script
and we have no idea what situation
they're going to put us in mm-hmm
so it's brand-new to us the five of us
but it gets you it's William Shatner
it's George Foreman yes it's a time yeah
Geoff dies and Terry Bradshaw Harry
Bradshaw
listen up America this is why I think
it's so funny is because you know you
spent so much time as just being known
as the Fonz bracele this character yeah
and I feel like at this point in your
life and who would have guessed that
because of shows like this probably
because of the stuff you did with Adam
Sandler because of interviews like this
that you've done you've
become known as Henry Winkler literally
true you and your actual personality
have become just as famous at this point
I feel well it's it's a wonderful thing
because then it's really easy to carry
the mantle of the Fonz with me you know
people talk to me all over the world
about the Fonz right they've seen other
stuff but that really connects with them
and it is a pleasure really
you've never went through a phase where
you were like I'm just yes you did I did
there was we made a first appearance at
a big store down in Neiman Marcus in
Dallas for boys Ron Howard and Sam
Williams Don most and me Wow
25,000 people standing between us and
the limousine Donny most a little
nervous got really screwed anyways how
are we gonna get out of here there are a
lot of people they're gonna they're
gonna rip us apart
Anson Williams said do we deserve this I
said that's not the point they're here
just say thank you right for the first
time I use the character off the show
and I said all right listen up
you're gonna pause like the Red Sea
you're gonna just and we're gonna walk
to a limousine and you're not gonna
touch us and I'm telling you it works
and we start walking and some girl said
oh my god
he's so short and I went hey [ __ ] you
I'm not sure and she went oh my goodness
he's so cool we got in that limousine
and we took off that's amazing because
it would have been it would have been a
terribly embarrassing moment if you try
to do the Fonz and people are like
that's a it's a TV show whatever I don't
care
but for some reason they just adopted
that character into their lives so much
that like yeah this is it was amazing
whatever he says goes I also love that
the Fonz curses off TV yeah well no you
but only like twice a year I see this
was it Terry Bradshaw on the show yeah
yeah
tries me did too tries to get me to go
whoa
give me a wall he says all the time he
put me in a stockade in Lithuania and he
said I you know I'm not letting you out
until you give me a whop I said no I
won't good for you he said give me a
whoa I said no I won't good for you then
Jeff guy comes over with an umbrella and
starts poking me in the gonads what give
me a window give me a whoa I said no
Jeff die he's poking you in the gotit
unbelievable yeah I can't believe it the
young kids I still have a band-aid you
would think that there'd be some respect
from a guy like him you would write for
me but instead he's a young
whippersnapper right instead he's
injuring he's injuring henry winkler's
testicles and with no remorse right just
now you look at his face and go I can't
believe really the savagery it's you
know what I'm gonna tell you something
yeah I saw an ancestor come right out in
that face really yes Wow yes Wow
why did you sign up or what got you to
sign up for a show like you know one is
that it's kind of scary to think about
yeah are you gonna go and travel not
knowing what you're going to do not
knowing where you're going to go for 40
days that's a long time yes because you
love your family yeah your life yeah I'd
be away for 40 days I love TiVo right
okay so to watch your program I attend
yeah yeah the meanwhile godless on
Netflix just thought I'd throw that out
right now are you gonna go to the movies
I go to movies all the time the shape of
water what's the shape of the shape of
water all I'm gonna tell you is to go
okay and when you come out you will be
elevated your life will have changed oh
we were talking about that's the
Guillermo del Toro's right it that you
got nominated for Golden Globe right and
it should right okay I'm gonna get
nominated from many many more Awards
seven golden the shape of water Wow
I will check it out okay I will see it
based on your recommender so you know
it's tough to travel and you get scared
and then they say you know that you're
gonna eat like a goat from the inside
out and I thought like I don't think
that I could eat a goat from the inside
out so I'm good now I don't know that
I'm going right and we talked about it
then we cast it took about a year and a
half to get all the guys
and we went on this trip to Asia first
and now Europe I'm telling you it's it's
not it's not like a normal TV show it is
a gift
right it's I mean it's it's a really
crazy premise and the names as we talked
about that you got for it are kind of
insane art where any of them difficult
to begin with even from the beginning
everybody know no one was difficult
unless you consider Bill Shatner
difficult that's what I wonder cuz
Shatner has kind of this he's prickly
but here's the thing he reveals himself
and there's this tender heart underneath
he's a horseman
he's a reader he's read every book you
know under the planet under the stars I
should say and he wants you to know
what's on every page were you excited
when you found out they were doing a
second season or were you like I don't
know excited excited excited excited
Berlin Munich Barcelona where I actually
pushed my envelope my personal living
envelope to the enth degree and became
the model for an art class nude I looked
like a Butterball turkey just had for
Thanksgiving
right I mean you never thought I could
have basted me you would never have
known the difference this is the first
time you've done nude work for yes it
was for Filmore telling us it was Wow
and at this point your life I thought
that my wife has ever seen me nude what
made you decide to just do it like are
you just thinking like who cares like I
did I put on everything there is to be
the creative executive producer I trust
him he is he just is incredibly
thoughtful and he asked me he the last
year when we were in Korea he said
you're gonna eat a raw octopus I said
listen I gotta just want to say
something I'll do anything I'll serve it
maybe I'll cut it maybe I'll do
commentary I'm not eating it
at 10:30 at night I ate it Wow
yeah that's that's gotta be the trick
right because all you guys have the the
I don't know not reputation but have the
have the ability right to say I'm not
doing that
like whoever it is Foreman Shatner Terry
Bradshaw you you could go on any TV show
anywhere and go like well no I'm I'm me
I'm not doing that ridiculous night and
they somehow just got I guess because
you're all in that boat if one wrong you
want you to do it one for all and all
for one and I have to say that in a
little hot oil a living squiggling
octopus is delicious how does it I'll
take your word for it how does it not
end up being a scenario where all of you
legends are just getting Jeff die to do
everything he's just this young comic
you know no Jeff is in charge of making
sure we're comfortable on making sure we
get from place to place he wasn't making
he wasn't in charge of making sure your
gonads were comfortable no he was not no
no he's not doing a very good no he you
know what he tries as hard as he
possibly can yeah but he needs to try
like a little hard yeah I'm not kidding
yeah but you know he's tall yes and for
that alone he gets to go that's it yeah
do you guys look at him like you know
how to be young tall and handsome again
well to be young and tall right I don't
know about handsome right he's a great
guy he's funny so uh Arrested
Development is coming back to them yes
we just did just before I came to New
York I finished all of my stuff for the
last season is there any Barry
zuckerkorn still doesn't know one thing
about the law that's great that's great
the minute he does by the way the series
is over yeah then we've ruined
everything
no but he has the confidence to say to
you right sitting across the desk from
me in your red and black plaid shirt
right I will take care of you if you've
got a legal problem right you put it in
my hands which isn't true it's not true
no but the confidence is I will add you
you will probably be executed by the
time I'm done but isn't it amazing that
I think that that in life we more
gravitate towards the people who even if
we know that they're not experts even if
we know they can't do anything as long
as they can talk to us confidently like
that we'll trust him mature which is one
of the four geniuses that I've worked
with in my life and he stands on the set
and he said say this say this says I say
this and but Mitch what I've said just
now is really funny yeah yeah yeah yeah
see this yeah it's really it's gonna be
funnier and it is Wow off the top of his
head just listening he just throws you
I'm gonna say this now but if here's the
great thing last year when we did it
yeah I talked to light stance I talked
to middle stands with pieces of tape on
them now over here is Jeff Tambor over
here is Jessica Walters over here is
Jason Bateman this year everybody was in
the room at the same time that's amazing
and I think that that was a question
that a lot of people had because people
as much as they were happy to see the
show back did kind of notice that you
had to do it in a creative way yes we
could to get all the players involved in
different times learn and and was that
because that scheduling yeah every I
know some stars are lazy you know some
stars are very very big and if you are
not brought to the set on an Egyptian
carry chair then they don't work who's
the laziest who some lazy is the laziest
of everybody on the set yeah I would
have to say David Cross is really
difficult David Cross yeah yeah he
doesn't like to leave Brooklyn no unless
it's on one of those contraptions you
just got you that someone carries and
yeah no is it was there any concern
after the after jeffrey tambor i guess
first he said he was leaving transparent
and then he said he might never see
after the allegations came out i have
acted with him for a few years i know
him i don't know
about that situation I just have to take
for granted that what is going down
actually happened but the dichotomy of
the human being of being so incredibly
talented in one area and losing their
way in the other somehow in the middle
is the truth right right and I think
people and it's like anything you know
it's like lifting people up and tearing
people down people love one or the other
America loves them yeah they hope they
love helping you and building you up and
then they love tearing you to bits like
wild dog right realizing like yeah we
can make this hero and then once you're
the hero it's like well you're not
better than us we're gonna put night and
I'll come back down come back right and
just and just leaving you in a pile but
but it didn't I didn't
there hasn't been any talk about
postponing the season not not to me I'm
only an actor on that I'm not an
executive producer so they talk to be
about nothing even when I'm on the set
no one talks to me that's terrible I
bring in chocolate cake right that I
have made in my house yeah and I bring
it in piping hot from scratch a bundt
cake because I don't like icing
necessarily okay and it's delicious
really moist
soaking chocolate chips that are
dripping into the the essence of the
Cassiar they don't give a [ __ ] they
don't care they don't he's a problem no
icing a lot of other people like I know
what I don't care because I like it not
eat it right if nobody else is gonna eat
my cake you'll help your so I have a lot
of it yeah and you know who also likes
the camera team they do the camera
department loves the bundt cake David
Cross won't have a bite I've never seen
him eat anything he doesn't eat no I see
a lot of lettuce I see he's one of those
types yeah one of those lettuce types
yeah so were you are you are you
surprised that Hollywood has kind of
been turned on its ass a little bit with
all these allegations and I mean
literally piling up you know yesterday
was Mario Batali it's it's everywhere
everywhere do you know look I don't know
what the individual situations are sure
sure I know some of these people
personally
I think probably it is a really good
idea for women to be taken seriously for
women to finally have a voice and not
just be told you have a voice be told
you have the opportunity to speak up at
any time but to actually have it have a
consequence have it matter you are how
old when when when you got the finds
only seven okay so you're your 20 year
in your late 20s and you're this
character yes it is the biggest thing in
the country yes how do you stop from
getting an ego that's totally out of
control do you know what is interesting
I don't know if this is true but this I
mean seriously the answer to that I am
dyslexic so learning challenges I think
effect emotionality like there are
pieces that don't always work I never
thought that I was a person but I never
I never thought I was whole okay so when
I became a star and uh I all of a sudden
you know people treated me differently
sure I realized I don't know how to
spell any better than I did before I was
on TV
maybe I'm the same guy and should just
shut up so you are so do you think that
that's kind of self esteem self esteem
is the beginning and the end of living
on this earth right and do you think
that having that learning disability
doesn't allow you to inflate your ego
you know because you know what you
especially when you're growing up you're
dreaming about being an actor yeah you
eat it you sleep it you lie in bed you
can't fall asleep you really want to do
this and yet you look around and
everybody can do geometry and you don't
know what the hell is going on I see and
it just you you start to believe what
everybody is saying you start to believe
you're stupid now when I go around and I
speak to students in schools that's my
phone that's okay that's I think my
daughter is calling me well
important you know no I don't tire it's
my son Jed Jed I'm on the radio right
now and I've got a hang-up okay I love
you Jed bye it's my oldest son how old's
Jed Jed is 35 and you still say I love
you every time you talk - I do that's
beautiful yeah so anyway when when you
see around you all the children are
doing well right and you're not your
self-esteem will drop to the bottom of
the ocean faster than a boulder and our
job is a friend as a cousin as a brother
sister mom dad is to bolster that
child's point of view self self vision
yes forever so at what point do you stop
feeling like a broken person right if
you're if you're if you're this famous
guy and you can't enjoy it because you
still feel broken now I would say
because you don't stand behind 72 years
old right now 10 years ago only 10 years
and 10 years ago so you're in your 60s
before you feel whole and I now AM just
becoming the actor that I fantasized at
being at 27 Wow and does that drive you
a little crazy drives me crazy if I
could have done this then yes yeah you
know that thing youth is wasted on the
young right it's no joke right so what
was it in your 60s that like well first
of all will you have to know what you
want yes if you know what you want and
there is no doubt you will move toward
that goal and you can live it I I
believe that's the way it works on this
earth I really believe that huh but you
have to know what you want and then you
just keep working and you move out of
your comfort zone and you push the limit
a little bit and you try something that
you're afraid to do but you know you
don't know how you're going to be
accepted for doing it but you go
anywhere and then all of a sudden boom
you're here sitting in this wonderful
soft chair talking to you right right
this is your dream come true you're
telling me right now this is great this
is the pinnacle it had to be very
difficult and this bottle of water
three bites kind of lukewarm but it's
not in the house yeah you take that wait
long
yeah do you must have been difficult
though to raise kids when you don't feel
whole yourself you know what that's a
very good point I probably would have
done an even better job if I if I was
holder yeah but here it is listening to
me honest to god the the most important
thing about raising children your ear
I'm going to a meeting you're late you
can't find your keys you are you either
traffic is going to be terrible you're
gonna miss the bus and your child says
dad I can I just say one thing and you
go can we talk about this later
can we out you know what tonight we'll
talk about it no you take 45 seconds you
slow down you turn around and you say
what is it Zoey and so he will get one
sentence sound she will feel heard she
will feel good you're not gonna be any
really later for the meaning for the bus
for the traffic for the better day today
right a heard child is powerful and it
gives you this this feeling of like okay
well I might not feel full let me not
pass that on to these kids that let me
make sure the way why don't be a
different parent yeah yeah then they the
parents that I grew up with and then on
a better life than ever we go to Berlin
and I literally traced my roots
I've never been to Berlin and I've never
really been emotionally attached really
to my family or the past I've seen
pictures but I was on an emotional
journey in through Berlin on better late
than never that I was not prepared for
so it's not just you know ridiculous
stunts in eating octopi and things like
that like you actually go on these
emotional journeys trips and you know
the guys share they share with each
other who they are what that moment was
that changed their lives it's really
compelling and funny did you ever in
your life because I feel like especially
show business is kind of flooded with
with people who have feelings of
jealousy and being cut and you know not
really just just wanting something
because the other person has it and I
need to make sure you don't strike me as
that type of person whatsoever is that
because I know you today or have you
always been this way I have been that
way I think most of my life but my wife
Stacy and our children and our
grandchildren are keep my feet on the
ground
I see they remind you right yeah I start
to believe in the way that you're
treated outside the house you you're in
deep trouble so you're talking about
kids being heard and raising your kids
differently when you were raised was it
that you weren't heard or was it I was a
different time wasn't seen I see I
literally I was it was severe my my
upbringing was severe as the word and is
that do you blame her you know the
opening song of of Oliver juries could I
have small right you know once I on an
assembly day an assembly day you wore a
white shirt and a tie and you went to
school it was the assembly day I
literally had the nerve to put my ear to
the bowl of cereal to hear snap crackle
and pop right talk to me and my mother
chased me around the dining room table
for real why I don't know I mean that's
what kids do you see the commercial and
you know what snap crackle and pop they
were lovely funny little
now does that boggle your mind because
like I have a I have a 10 month old son
and I feel like if you were a little
older and he were of the age to do that
I would think like it's adorable
and actually just enjoy the fact that
he's enjoying anything
there's my comic there's gonna come a
time in the next two years when he is
going to have a birthday cake in front
of him with two candles three candles
and he's gonna blow those candles out
and then he is going to decide all on
his own that he should plant his face in
the middle of that cake that seems like
it's gonna be a great thing it's a great
thing
so does it do you look back and go like
I don't understand how my mother I look
back now the mature part of me should
understand the child in me doesn't
understand the they're not lined up yet
so I I don't understand as as well as I
should was their mental illness god
that's a good question I don't know
because the counseling I don't know to
get mad you know yeah well you know they
escaped Nazi Germany they left
everything behind huh there was there
was a severity to their life also door
except at that age I couldn't put that
all together right I couldn't go well
all right I see you've got a problem
you're not gonna see your parents again
well mom you just be an [ __ ] okay
doesn't add up when you're just getting
amused at your your cereal pipe 72 I'm
just getting there did you ever go into
therapy I have yeah I have
are you are you an advocate for did you
like it well you know what for each
individual sure for each individual III
said once to my therapist I said if I
were to give you a gift it would have to
be a skyscraper to thank you for what I
have received
wow so you loved it I did yeah and then
it brought you is that what kind of it
over on you too getting a photo yes I am
grateful I am I'm weepy but I am
grateful at this moment to have
just gotten a better vision of myself in
the world and then I'm able to see the
world
sure in a different way was there
anything that now that your kids are
grown have they come back to you and
said like yeah I kind of [ __ ] me up
when you did this dad you didn't even
realize like oh no I didn't we have a
son Max Max has a new movie that is
coming out in March March 16th with Zoe
Deutsch and Kathryn Hahn it's called
flower uh-huh and when he did his first
movie with uma Thurman called ceremony
he said to us we read in People magazine
I believe it was in People magazine
imagine this your parents your proud
your son he said attend I'm gonna be a
director he's doing it oh my god we read
the article and it says my biggest
problem is that I was loved too much you
just can't win you can't win so I we
said to max you know I want to just say
max we would do exactly the same thing
over again if you were loved too much
shame on your poor back Oh max so do you
think some of your best acting work I
saw on your Twitter you were promoting
the HBO show that's coming out with Bill
Hader hell Barry
you must be the fact that you're the
actor that you want to be right now you
must be psyched about this show coming
yes and I it is it's amazing
Bill Hader and Alec Berg Alec Berg who
is also I think the the co-creator of
Silicon Valley right
he is also the co-creator of Barrie oh
that's great those two together their
combo they are two of the S together
they are a genius in the four geniuses
that I so Mitch Hurwitz Bill Hader and
Alec Burke together that's what I count
the two of them counted down as one they
are brilliant men who are the other two
Garry Marshall okay and Adam Sandler
okay Adam Sandler for his goofy as he
seems on the screen right
is in charge of every detail of a movie
that he's in do you think Adam Sandler
like how does he deal with the fact that
like he went through a pretty
substantial period of time where people
were kind of treating him like a joke he
was just beloved guy right and then it
became very cool to make fun of Adam
Sandler you know here's the thing he
always stuck to who he was right he does
he always sticks to who he was Gary
Marshall said a great thing he said you
know a lot of people make of important
television I make recess and he
understood his leash and Adam Sandler
breaks out you know the meyerwitz which
is the movie that is out now you know
that he's in is a completely different
role a really it's a very mature acting
role he can do it all yeah